- [Narrator] This
animation is brought to you
by Skillshare, an online
learning community
with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative people.
Explore new skills,
deepen existing passions,
and get lost in creativity.
- [Narrator] A coronary
angioplasty procedure is also known
as percutaneous coronary intervention.
The procedure is done on blood vessels
called coronary arteries.
They supply your heart muscle with oxygen.
The goal is to restore
blood flow if a substance
called plaque has significantly
narrowed these vessels.
To begin the procedure,
the doctor will numb
the skin in your groin.
A needle will be placed through your skin
and into the femoral artery.
Next, a flexible guide wire will be passed
through the needle into your artery.
Then, the needle will be withdrawn.
It will be exchanged
for a small, flexible
tube called a sheath.
This permits access into your artery.
You may feel pressure when
the doctor inserts the sheath,
but you will not feel it
moving inside your artery.
Next, the guide wire will be
advanced up to your heart.
A flexible tube called a
catheter will be advanced
over the wire to your coronary arteries.
The progress of the
procedure will be checked
with an X-ray device called a fluoroscope.
At this point, your doctor
will remove the guide wire.
Then, the doctor will move
the tip of the catheter
just inside the coronary
artery to be examined.
A special dye will be
injected into the artery.
This allows your doctor to view it better
with a fluoroscope.
The dye will make any blockages
in the artery stand out.
If a significant blockage is found,
your doctor will insert a
guide wire into the artery.
A balloon on the tip of
the catheter will be moved
along the wire to the blockage.
When the balloon inflates,
it will expand the artery
and improve the blood flow.
You may feel some chest discomfort
while this is happening.
After this, your doctor will
deflate and remove the balloon.
A wire mesh tube called
a stent may be placed
in the treated area.
The stent helps keep the
coronary artery open.
Your doctor will choose
the proper size stent,
which is compressed over a balloon.
The stent will be moved into the artery
over the same guide wire.
When the balloon is inflated,
the stent will expand and lock into place.
After the balloon catheter is taken out,
the stent will stay in place
to hold the artery open.
At the end of the procedure,
the guide wire will be removed.
To find out more about
coronary artery angioplasty,
talk to your healthcare provider.
- [Narrator] Skillshare is
an online learning community
with thousands of inspiring
classes for creatives.
It's curated specifically for learning,
meaning there are no ads,
and they're always launching
new premium classes,
so you can stay focused
and follow wherever your
creativity takes you.
And it's less than $10 a month
with an annual subscription.
If you wanna learn how to use
the same software programs
we use at Nucleus, Skillshare has hundreds
of courses for you on Cinema 4D,
Adobe After Effects, and ZBrush.
They offer courses on how to
create micrograph images in C4D
so your cellular animations
look realistic and cinematic
and much, much more.
Take advantage of Skillshare's free trial
for premium membership by
clicking the link below
in the video description.
Sign up and explore your creativity.